this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode he's taking another
look at the military sim shooter squad
first impression of this sks really nice
case ejection being able to see the the
cartridge case come out realistically
not just sideways spinning through the
air and arcing gracefully into the into
the sand very nicely done if you're a
fan of squad definitely make sure to
check out our previous video in the game
and if there are any other games guns or
mechanics you guys want to see jonathan
break down let us know in the comment
section below right let's check out the
weapons of squad
i'm sure i've played a game with a with
an fn mag or mag or mag58
whatever you'd like to call it but i
can't think of one um so first reaction
is it's nice to see this this is the
standard british army general purpose
machine gun nicknamed jimpy uh the
general and just good old gpmg depending
on which service you're in used by of
course many different countries and of
course the u.s military as well as the
m240 or n240b i believe it is for the
infantry version which is what we have
here and the very first thing i saw
there was a very nicely depicted and
nice nice sounding actually bipod that
flicked out for use on top of these
hesco containers that we're using here
now something that is going to be very
hard to solve and i haven't seen solved
yet is a believable interface between
bipod legs and ground or whatever
surface you're resting on as brilliantly
modeled as this is and as the surfaces
are there's still that weird floaty
disconnect between bipod and what you're
resting it on and i don't think game
engines are quite there yet in terms of
making that look right otherwise the
sort of drills look good maybe a little
bit sort of tentative and ginger with
with how the the feed device is being
connect uh
installed and the top cover is being
lifted up normally you'll see a lot more
slapping it pretty hard and operating it
with authority with something like a
machine gun but
it's looking really good now as you know
i like to grab
rare and important versions of these
various guns that we're seeing in these
games from the collection to show you
now so this is an earlier type gun
reason i've grabbed this one which is
otherwise very plain and ordinary
is its
serial number one as far as i know it is
literally
zero zero one
belgian
fn mag now if anyone knows different who
knows of another serial number one let
me know because it seems that we have
somehow managed to get hold of fn's
first ever production fn mag-58
so i'm seeing a lot of hip firing here
now that's
it's realistic and it's not i think i
think video game usage obviously
encourages the use of hip firing way
beyond what you would normally try to do
with a weapon like this you want it
stable on the ground you want to be
prone behind it or at least behind a
wall or something with it resting firmly
on the wall it's extremely heavy some
argue too heavy to be used from the
shoulder or the hip i mean you can
certainly do it for at least for short
periods how effective the resulting fire
is going to be is is really what's a
question here but so what we see is
plausible enough but i don't think you'd
be doing it as much as you're doing it
which
turns it more from nitpicking over guns
to
straying into areas of tactics
techniques tactics and procedures which
is not not quite my wheelhouse i suppose
my expertise um
intersects with that but it's not it's
not my background so i defer to the to
the soldiers and the
military types but yeah a bit too much i
mean i couldn't do it put that put it
that way
[Applause]
right first impressions
of the ef ef-88 are very good really
nicely modeled the see-through bits look
good i might sound silly but um growing
up in the days of solid solid polygons
or even bitmap images floating in front
of my face i very much appreciate true
3d things that you can see through uh
and the architecture of the the af-88
allows you to show off a bit of that
we've got the the sort of see-through
picatinny rail bit underneath the
lightning and then the the holes in the
polymer receiver itself so you can see
something of what's inside which is
quite cool apart from anything else but
for me it's nice to see it modeled
correctly details like the fluted barrel
um little clamp on bayonet log this is
all really nice now i don't have an
example to compare this to and nitpick
over long story short it's very
expensive and difficult to to get
weapons of this type into the country
and into our hands intact so as yet we
don't have an ef-88 in case you're
wondering ef-88 is not some legal
evasive name this is an actual type of
rifle very clearly it's derivative
relatively closely derivative of the
stay aug in fact i'd say there are two
parallel development strands now one is
the original austrian one and then the
australian which was a
the f-88 we do have an example of the
f-88 but not the ef-88 e for enhanced
various ergonomic improvements you
probably saw the bolt catch being
operated there basically a complete
redesign in detail it's recognizably an
aug but it's the australian variant of
it
okay now the hk 417 is something we do
have
in the collection and it is
the same generation as depicted here i
believe now i'm not particularly okay
with the australian trials process i do
know that this is an interesting point
actually in terms of nomenclature if you
find such things interesting which which
we do in this world is the australians
adopted this as the hk417 which is its
commercial product name effectively the
in-game version is marked
f417 or 417. i don't know if that's
due to happen or yeah and any australian
military types please do
correct us on that one this is a
reaction video so i haven't had time to
check on that but um as far as i know
it's just called hk417
because only small numbers are in use
with australian
sf as we would call them but yeah this
is basically what you see
in front of you so unlike the british
army's uh adopted sharpshooter rifle
which is semi-automatic only the 417 and
i assume the australian version as well
is select fire so you can use it as a
sort of well what people often call a
battle rifle
full power 7.62 nato
chambered rifle able to deliver
automatic fire but you're only going to
want to do that in an emergency because
it isn't going to be very controllable
to put it mildly so yeah this is a
another one of our future museum pieces
if you like we have preserved it because
it was involved in trials in the uk
now it's good to see some variety in
well everything i suppose but uh
kalashnikov rifles in particular and
we've got a couple of different ak-74
variants so the ak-74m with the black
furniture the folding stock the sight
rail on the side that's still the
standard russian military rifle for the
time being what we're seeing at the
moment is its immediate predecessor
effectively well the
ak-s-74 not the aks-74eu
which is probably more famous and more
included in video games but just the aks
74 is what i'm holding and waving about
at the moment it does have the prototype
sort of of the
side folding buttstock
that's on the 74m the ak-100 series the
ak200 series but it's the same it's the
same um
rear trunnion hinged folding mechanism
the little catch
on the side of the receiver that you
just have to press to release
and unfold and that when you
press in the catch of the rear and fold
just catches the butt it's a really good
design and copying that effectively
copying your own homework to create the
solid polymer version for the ak-74m
was an excellent idea otherwise it's
absolutely standard ak-74 so distinctive
muzzle brake
um although less distinctive now because
a version of this is on almost every
modern kalashnikov rifle so you can no
longer use this as oh that's an ak-74
because it could be an ak-103 anyway
we're going too far down the rabbit hole
here i just thought i'd grab the aks-74
because it's one of the ak's that gets
perhaps less attention
in video games
wow some really impressive explosions
and sound effects there i have to say
that you only of course get with
anti-tank weapons very nicely done
on two counts we've got two variants
here uh the m2 which you've seen the
cheesy thumbnail of me wielding
previously we do have one because it's
1980s vintage bit like me the m3 is the
other version that we see there looking
a little bit more high-tech with a
better optic but then we've also got
different ammunition types now that's
something that's rarely modeled for in
games um good to see we've got a smoke
round which actually could be could be
pretty useful and two anti-tank or at
least two high explosive patterns of
munition one conventional high explosive
anti-tank or heat and one with a tandem
warhead now as i'm sure a lot of you
already know tandem warheads are
normal-sized warheads with little baby
ones on the front that
sort of clear the path for the main
warhead the way the way a shaped charge
works
it has to initiate correctly to generate
this jet of particles
that punches through armor so you get
two for the price of one sort of and the
little one on the front will sort of
take the hit for if it's bar armor
that's defeating it and explosive
reactive it will effectively defeat that
like it's a layer of armor and then the
main warhead follows up and then that
initiates and goes through the standard
steel now i'm not sure what the downside
would be to using not just going
straight to the tandem warhead in a game
where
cost and weight extra weight aren't so
much of an issue but there may be an
in-game reason why probably probably
limited availability of rounds i would
guess but i haven't played the game to
figure that out but nice to see
different warheads
depicted
now another 762 armor light based
designated marksman rifle the american
m110 semi-automatic sniper rifle
sass
sas and it does have a lot of sass at
least compared to a 556
rifle of almost any kind very very much
along the same lines as the hk417
but of course each country each armed
force has its own selection process and
they end up with different similar
rifles so m110 is a u.s military
designation but this is the product of
knights armament corporation um over in
florida and i suppose the the the
biggest difference to most users of the
get in the game is going to be it's
desert coloured certain rifles and
firearms generally come in different
default colors of course the variety of
colors now is such that you can
basically choose what you want like a
car when you put in an order for however
many you want but we do tend to see the
m110 in desert tan and the hk417 more so
in black but they're yeah that's that's
by no means a rule yeah you had to pick
one or the other i would say very little
to choose between them that said we
don't have an m110 so if anyone would
like to donate one
to the collection
less snow
[Applause]
now you reckon you'll recognize no doubt
the name minimi inevitably calls to mind
dr evil but uh anyway what it actually
means is uh miniature mitreose which is
french from machine gun so
compress that together so this was
designed as a counterpart to the
existing successful
mag or mag 58 substantially different
design from scratch to fire 556
ammunition optionally with a magazine as
well from a from a cult armor-like style
box magazine infamously that does not
work brilliantly well a friend of mine
um larry zanoff managed to pull that off
in the marvel movies so we see bucky
barnes with a 60 round magazine sticking
out of his gun running flawlessly that's
down to larry but the main feed is of
course as with most
light machine guns belt feed which is
what we see
nicely modelled
in the game now um i haven't just
grabbed this because why not and this is
actually an
australian contract example of the fn
minima now we only know that from the
serial number which has an am
prefix this is not marked up
with australian
government or military markings it is a
bog standard fn minima now we know this
thing from an awful lot of computer and
video games good to see you in its
intended role depicted as a proper
military light machine gun rather than
just as something for the protagonist to
run around ramboing with which is what
we normally see takes on on the enemy in
computer games it has sort of captured
the popular imagination it's compact a
lot of firepower it's controllable
[Applause]
right now this is an interesting
mini narrative within this review so
we've gone from the classic minime 556
light machine gun a us special
operations command requirement
so i think navy seals in particular here
led to
a weird sort of circular story where the
minime got
scaled up
to fire the 7.62 nato round so what did
they want there well they wanted this
power the firepower of the 762 round
with
the lightweight of the minime now that's
impossible
basically speaking they couldn't make it
as light and handy as the minimi but
they could make it lighter and handier
than the m240 to be fair to the fn mag
that was designed as a general purpose
machine gun it's bit too heavy for for
use
or heavier than it perhaps needed to be
as a squad level weapon fn went back to
the drawing board sort of
and instead of lightening the fn mag
they decided to go for the the already
light minimi and upscale it to 7.62 and
my arm is starting to feel that
because this is
the
so called maximi i think this is well
done uh the big shame of having this
mark 48 in the game would be if you
couldn't really tell the difference
between either this and the minime or
this and the mag 58 now without actually
sort of getting hands on i can't quite
get the sense of how it sort of handles
in the game but it certainly looks and
sounds
right so it's punchier but lower rate of
fire which would expect from 7.62 and it
seems to be more wieldy than the gpmg
the l7 or the the c6
that could be my
imagination
[Applause]
a bit of a legacy type there the former
soviet rpd is a light machine gun
chambered in the 7.62 by 39 cartridge of
the kalashnikov and the sks rifle i
don't know if that was my eyes but
anyway the the cartridges looked a
little long in the case to be 762 by 39
they looked a bit more like 762
54 only not rimmed so i don't know it's
either they're either slightly too long
or i'm just losing the plot one of the
two good depiction of the rpd uh we see
them less and less i think in conflict
zones because the pkm is just so much
better in just about every respect but
they're still out there so many of these
things are made that they are certainly
still out there and still viable and
still used probably the most distinctive
thing about it is that hand grip here we
can see why it's shaped the way it is
because it's actually being grasped in
what's now called thumb over ball so
a supposedly modern grip in which
your thumb goes over the top of your
barrel
for extra control especially under uh
automatic fire now there's some sort of
convergent design there they wanted a
nice secure grip whether you gripped it
underneath like a conventional hand grip
or whether you wrapped your thumb over
the top for extra control and the sights
that normally problem wrapping your
thumb over the top of a firearm
handguard is that your thumb might
obscure your sights well the way this
gun's designed
that doesn't happen
[Applause]
right first impression of this sks
really nice case ejection um i can't
remember if that's correct to the type i
haven't put enough round through sks's
to remember that but being able to see
the the cartridge case come out
realistically not just sideways as they
sometimes used to spinning through the
air and within camera arcing gracefully
into the into the sand very nicely done
and then quite a cool partial top off
reload so we're holding the working
parts to the rear and inserting more
rounds into the magazine rather than
using a stripper to
completely fill the internal but
openable magazine that's by default on
the sks as i'm sure most of you already
know by this point
and now we see the stripper clip reload
which would be the normal reload you'd
normally shoot to empty and then insert
around a fresh clip of 10 rounds which
what we see and we even see the very
nice touch of levering up the top most
round in the clip which gives you a bit
more i guess mechanical advantage to
push the whole stack around into the
action that's something i've seen
recommended and have tried myself in
other words the developers here are
depicting naturalistic operation of
firearms rather than hyper stylized as
we used to
okay
rare to see a bayonet used i think it's
fair to say in a modern fps of course
the sks comes with a handy one fitted to
the rifle at all times now i have
thankfully never had to bayonet anyone
nor been bayonetted but from everything
i've read and heard i'm not sure that a
knife type blade like that would go so
cleanly and kill so cleanly into
multiple layers of fabric equipment
and then into the human body suffice to
say killing people with bayonets is not
necessarily straightforward at least not
with a modern lightweight short rifle
with a bayonet of that type of pattern
we've noticed it with bullets so i think
it's worth commenting on with blades as
well yeah a bit too quick and clean
if you'd like to support our work here
at the royal armouries museum we do have
the usual link in the description and
you're very welcome to come and visit
our physical sites have a look at the
website on various social media channels
maybe come and join me over on our
youtube channel which at the moment is
quite me heavy so if you enjoy that sort
of thing please do join us over there
either way i'll see you next week
[Music]
you